reaction to the ongoing Cavanaugh
confirmation saga president of the New
York Civil Rights Coalition former vice
president of the ACLU Michael Meyers
you saw the ad we played last night
Michael for what since 1981 to 2005 you
were a member high-ranking member of the
ACLU I was a National Board of the
American Civil Liberties Union I was
also a building member of most of those
years on the ACLU National Executive
Committee how do you feel I I was
proudest of the ACLU and they still you
resisted fashion when it stood up to the
mob now the ACLU has become the mob and
it has it has become what you're not
supposed to be is supposed to stand up
to the mob it's supposed to stand for
freedom and individual liberty it's
supposed to stand for the presumption of
innocence and it doesn't make it doesn't
make assumptions it makes the
presumption that a person is a person is
presumed to be innocent unless he is
proven guilty beyond a reasonable doubt
in terms of civil manner the person is
innocent and left it a preponderance of
the evidence
Michael the agent happen to you now it's
hijacked by the lunatic left they don't
believe in process they don't believe in
due process I don't believe in free
speech anymore I don't believe in in
anything other than the resistance or as
opposed to resisting fashion they have
become part of the resistance movement
where does this end Michael to see the
civil libertarians come back to where
you are or you know do you now join
people like me which I know will give
you know send shockwaves through your
your spine well let's put it this way
the ACLU is we come with the
n-double-a-cp once you once you lose
control your board once you don't have
no civil libertarians on the board you
don't have a civil liberties algorithm
more and you and you have people who are
bottom line lunatics and turns on the
left they want quantum quote just stirs
so if a woman accuses a man the mayor
accusation is enough for the ACLU this
has never been a principle of civil
liberties
you can't kill somebody and don't expect
evidence to show the person who's guilty
of something and you can't presume a
person is guilty as opposed to innocent
Michael there are people like you Alan
Dershowitz in this case you stand alone
and you've been consistent in your views
of great admiration for both of you on
this case thank you both thank you for
being with us